hi
how are you i am very well how about you
uh yeah i'm doing i'm doing pretty well
thanks mate i'm doing pretty well yeah
the sun's just started shining in
england which is a rarity so
yeah i'm enjoying it very nice well i
appreciate you talking to me about this
i
have i just absolutely love this show i
must admit to being
one of those people who was not a sports
fan at all so i was dragged into
watching this
originally kicking and screaming because
i was sure i would hate it
and instantly fell in love with it it
keeps getting better and better and i'm
loving the episodes i've seen of season
two so
thank you and we got you we got you
yeah do you have a sense of how special
this show is from the beer very
beginning or did it take you time to
realize just how special it is
yeah it's a good question i think that i
mean
i certainly didn't think i don't think
you one ever make one ever thinks when
they make a show that that it will sort
of capture the hearts and minds in the
way that this
seems to have done uh but you know i
think that it certainly felt like you
know
anything that jason siddakis is at the
helm of feels like it's going to be a
bit special
um and uh it was really exciting to be
doing this with apple
um but i mean you know i think that
it was funny you know we enjoyed it
it's kind of like you know that i i've
done a lot of theater in my time
and the thing of thinking in rehearsals
you're like well
we find it funny but until you get in
front of an audience it's really hard to
know
um so yeah we we knew that it was a show
that promoted kindness and generosity of
spirit but
um we just you know it's it's hard to
know if people
if it's really going to capture the
imagination and it
seems to have done in a small way yeah
this show was great from the first
episode but it it still managed to get
better and better throughout the season
because of that how nervous were you
about season two did you ever wonder if
the first season was just some fluke and
then it would be all downhill from there
and season two would just
suck i mean how was it like when you got
a script were you like okay now i can
breathe a sigh of relief
yeah yeah yeah i mean you know the the
difficult the
the other side of the coin of that that
of of having all of those lovely things
that people say about it
is that there's the pressure of making
it good because you you're responsible
for those people now
um and it's a wonderful responsibility
to have but
it's the difficult second second album
where you're like we got to get this
right guys and
and yes exactly as you say i read the
script i was like
they got it they've done it they've got
it somehow they have managed to harness
all those wonderful things that we
thought about
the characters from the first season
um and they have continued that through
the second season
and i think they just really added to it
in really beautiful ways
uh in really clever ways added new uh uh
characters that you're gonna absolutely
love and and yeah it's uh
it's it's a real it's a real joy to have
been a part of
knowing that that uh that i think that
they really smashed it
with the way that the first season ended
especially for your character did they
tell you
then what their ideas would be for him
for season two or did you have to wait
to find out what his journey would be
uh yeah i think in terms of the
specifics of it
i don't know if uh i really knew exactly
what was going to be happening
uh you know certainly uh
until much closer to when we started
season two
did i know that jamie was gonna be
appearing in the way that jamie appears
at the start of season two
uh which is a lot of fun um
but uh yeah i mean you know one of the
incredible things about doing
a show like this is that jason sedakis
knows
the whole he has it all mapped out in
his head um
it's kind of like i imagine it's a bit
like uh the tattoos in prison break if
you cut jason open it's
probably like that but with the story of
ted lasso if you're very curious
uh but uh yeah so so he he always knew i
think and he would allude to it jason
would do this incredible thing
he'd sit down with every member of cast
as it were came to a scene
and uh would would walk you through
where the character's been where the
character is going so that you can have
a really good idea
when you're doing the scene um so yeah
there were there were certain elements
that i was uh aware of
um but but but yeah i think that he
likes to just
tease a little bit with us to let us
sort of wanting more
since jamie is not someone who's known
to be very aware of other people's
feelings or really even in touch with
his own
feelings what's it like to get to play
him
a little bit more self-aware this season
and a little bit more
knowledgeable of how he's affecting
other people
yeah right doc dude thank you thank god
that you're
you know you're listening to other
people now yeah uh
yeah he's he's learning what empathy
maybe might mean
um yeah it's it's um
it's it's it's kind of in a way it's
more challenging because
it just means that there's more light
and shade to him now
whereas before it was pretty
straightforward um you know
he had his demons that that were sort of
sat on his shoulder but
uh it was it was pretty more
straight clear-cut that he was a bit
more of an antagonist in the show but
now he is you know he's a
a fallen devil i guess uh
whereby he you know he really was just
truly much out and out selfish arrogant
young man but
now he's a sort of a selfish arrogant
young man in recovery and
and i think that it's a real treat to
play that because
it's it's a lot more complicated than
just someone who is
mean um so but that's what you want
right like as an actor that's what you
want you want that sort of those
challenging roles where
um you want to try to portray that and
also be funny because you know it's a
comedy
so uh yeah it's there's a lot to get
your teeth into
we also get introduced this season to
lead tasso
so how does jv feel about that happening
compared to
ted lasso does he just think he's crazy
well phil speaking in third person
pointing to oneself
uh thought that led taser was a lot of
fun
because um you know it was this alter
ego
and uh jason was clearly having a lot of
fun
doing it but uh
yeah i think that uh i think that that
that
jamie is aware that he's up to something
uh
and he this is at a time when jamie is
trying to
um ingratiate himself with the rest of
the team and i think that he kind of
feels like
you know he kind of he kind of feels
like
maybe what led tasso is doing is
is is not so conducive to him you know
uh to everyone having to a good
team mentality and so you know maybe
jamie wants to
he doesn't feel like this is right and
from what he's learned of good teamwork
over the last
season maybe he's gonna sort of try to
say something to to put that right
um so yeah jamie's a bit perplexed by
this led tasso fella
what aspect of your character would you
say is most like you
what aspect is least like you and is
there an aspect of him that you wish you
had yourself
uh the
element that is most like me
is probably um
oh wow it's probably the inability to
dress with class and style uh
that's probably how we are most similar
uh the thing that's least like me is
probably
jamie's uh absolute
assertiveness and conviction uh in what
he believes
and you know he's pretty congruent with
what he thinks and what he says
uh and the thing that i most wish that i
had
man his skills his skills on the ball
because i play a lot of football but let
me tell you
i am nowhere near as good as jamie tart
so i wish that i could play football
like he does
what have you enjoyed about the real
dynamic that he's developed with keely
as opposed to just
the superficial one they used to have
has it been fun to explore a new side of
that relationship
yeah absolutely you know he's he's
trying to live wholeheartedly i think
to to steal a phrase from dame brene
brown
uh he's trying to get into the arena
and he's he's you know he's trying to be
better he's trying to you know work
harder at himself
and um and i think that that keeley is
somebody who's really trying to draw
that out of him
and who respects him for for dealing
with
how he feels um and um
and you know i think that i think that
i think that that uh we see a different
side of jamie when he's talking to keely
a softer
more vulnerable side and i think that
you know that's i
i think that's a really important thing
for us to see this sort of
to begin with ultimately like masculine
idea
of an alpha someone who you know pushes
other people down rather than pulls them
up
and you know being vulnerable and saying
i'm sorry and you know
trying to be better is a really
wonderful thing to see
somebody who maybe wasn't like that
before trying to
well thank you for talking to me about
the show i love it i can't wait to see
the rest of the season
so thank you thank you very much thank
you for your time